have Thor bjornsen better known as the
mountain that rides on HBO's Game of
Thrones isn't just one of the strongest
people on TV he's one of the strongest
people in the world out of this lean and
mean Icelander become the most fearsome
Knight and all of Westeros it hasn't
always been pretty bjornsen was always a
big person but before he was the
freakishly huge Mad Dog of the
Lannisters he was more tall than he was
wide instead of weightlifting he put his
talents to use as a professional
basketball player in Iceland's first
division as a younger man
bjornsen says his weight hovered around
the 230 pound range which is nothing
compared to the near 400 pounds he
eventually achieved he said in an
interview with GQ I was always taller
than everybody else
I've been training all my life but
probably didn't grow muscley until I
quit doing basketball his naturally
large frame gave him a big advantage on
the basketball courts but he also was
dedicated to working out and getting
better speaking to men's health he said
I was a bit crazy and trained a lot
probably three times a day before school
then afterwards plus I was lifting at
night his intense work ethic paid off on
the court but his basketball days were
plagued by a recurring ankle injury
which ultimately dashed his hoop dreams
he told GQ I was always getting injured
I injured my ankles quite badly I had to
have surgery so the second time I had an
operation I decided to take a break from
basketball to heal my foot after
basketball bjornsen wasn't sure what to
do with himself already accustomed to a
heavy training regimen bjornsen decided
to stay the course and keep working out
but instead of going hard in the paint
he went to work in the weight room
focusing his energy on simply improving
his body he told GQ I just fell in love
with the weights fell in love with
training hard started to put weight on
quite fast started to get strong really
fast I saw results over the next few
years weightlifting turned into a
healthy addiction for bjornsen and the
Icelander nearly doubled his body weight
of course weightlifting alone can't turn
a 240 pound basketball player into the
mountain that rides it may not surprise
you to learn that the mountain that
rides eats a mountain of food every day
breaking down his diet 2gq he said I eat
a lot of sweet potatoes a lot of meats
fish chicken good fats like cocoa butter
almond
I love greens like spinach avocado
broccoli I eat very healthy overall it
sounds great but how much is a lot
exactly full vote the Orson requires a
total intake of some ten thousand
calories a day and there's really only
one way for him to fit all that food
into his stomach never stop eating as
bjornsen told GQ if you don't eat you
don't grow it's just like constantly
work for me I have to eat every two
hours to maintain my body mass we're not
talking about grazing throughout the day
here either
bjornsen reckons he devours around six
to eight full meals a day even for a
giant like him such a feat is not easy
especially when he's at work shooting
Game of Thrones
though bjornsen focuses mostly on heavy
weight lifting and strength training he
doesn't always stick to the same
workouts instead he believes it's
crucial to mix things up according to
bjornsen there's more to being an
accomplished strongman than simply
putting on more muscle as he told the
New York Times
you can't just be strong you have to be
quick you have to have flexibility for
that reason you can sometimes find him
out doing cardio exercises such as
swimming biking or even jogging with
this adorable Pomeranian the freakish
big and freakish stronger and quicker
than you'd expect for a man of that size
exercising the entire body is crucial to
seeing results especially when you're
already as huge as bjornsen
he told Men's Health when people ask me
about my routine it's hard to say
because I change it every week if you
always train the same way your body gets
used to it and you stop seeing results
after a few weeks
bjornsen is big but he's not interested
in getting bigger instead he's aiming to
improve the body he already has he told
GQ getting bigger isn't a big deal for
me I don't want to get bigger but having
a nicer body and being stronger is
definitely something I'm aiming for on
April 14th 2019 the day of the season
premiere of the final season of Game of
Thrones
ESPN's East 60 documentary series aired
an interview that conducted with
bjornsen back in 2017 where the star
revealed that he has used steroids have
I
yes some of both bjornsen and his family
expressed fears about his health due to
his extreme training regimen but when
pressed as to why he decided to take
steroids spirits and replied when you
want to be the best and do without
antics he finally won the World's
Strongest Man competition in 2018 check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]